こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん最近あっ
た動画見られましたでしょうか最近あった
動画それはクレーンゲームゲームセンター
にあるクレーンゲーム前代撮ったら何円
かかるのかという動画撮らせていただいた
んですけれどもまあことごとくことごとく
20万ぐらいかかってしまいましたA
ダイハツさんダイハツさんなんですけども
20万円近くかけた甲斐もありご覧
くださいこちら手に入れた商品です結構
ありますよ100台近くあったのでかなり
商品は多いです多い所じゃないなだって
全部取ったんだもんゲーセンのかなり量が
あるんですけども
[音楽]
と本音を言うとですよ本当に20万の価値
があるのかわからない
商品は知ってるわけじゃないですゲーセン
のこういうのってさ
蔓延するんかなっていう決まった金額が
あるわけじゃないじゃないですかクレーン
ゲームって100円で取れる人もいれば中
には7000円取れる人もあるこいつの
価値は100円から7000円前後なん
ですよそんなゲームセンターのクレーン
ゲームで撮れる価値のわからないものが
これだけあると売ったら何円になるのか
売ったら何になるのか気になりませんが皆
さん僕は気になりましたのでちょっと中に
は欲しいものとか好きなアニメのとこも
めっちゃあるんですけどもそこをグッと
こらえて今日はゲームセンタークレーン
ゲームで撮ったものを全て売ると何円に
なるのかやっていきたいと思います
[音楽]
だらけだけど
気になりゃ20万円相当かけたものを売る
と何なのか本来の価値とまではいかない
けどももちろん中古だし何円分戻ってくる
のがちょっとやってみたいと思います
なんかうわぶれねえかな限定の超人気
グッズとか人気キャラクターのでなんか
一番とか言ったらマジで最高
とりあえずちょっと取った景品見ていき
たいと思います何を売るのが説明したい
まずはこちらこの辺さんのうさぎですね
これこのへいさんは人気ですからそこそこ
値段がするのかなとは思いますけど
ぬいぐるみの相場ってわかんないんだよな
どんぐらいなんだろう2000円とかだ
けど中としたら
200円200円とかなんかなわかんない
新品だったら2000円知らんけど
スパイファミリーのアーニャです好き
かわいいですねおもちゃも持ってるし多分
400円高いかなわかんないマジ相場
分かんないマジ適当に言ってます100
種類のカラーペンですねちょっと実用的だ
なこれ売れるんかなそもそもちょっと個人
的に素敵だなと思って欲しかったんだけど
な100種類もあればそこそこ高い
でしょう1000円ぐらいな気がします
マジで独断と偏見で行くねおにぎり持った
猫ちゃん申し訳ない50円です
ちょっとかわいらしいデフォルメされた
アーニャ200円そんなする
窓付きの収納ボックスですねタオルとか
入れれるやつですねいや結構しっかりし
てるから割といきそうだけどな100円
スイカードサンリオのコラボ収納ボックス
これキャラパワーがあるので200円です
通信50円スイカはこのサイズのはそんな
に値段変わらないと思います100円
100円だと思う
50円個人的にお気に入りでしたなんか犬
の
狼のやつ50円ですマスコット50円
50円いや
10円
わかんないそんなにこんなちっちゃいのに
値が張らないと思うなこのサイズで50円
やばい全く商品名ないのがあるプリキュア
の何かかなマジでわかんないですけど
10円文房具マスコットのノート5円
もふもふの犬30円この犬可愛いなでも
ちっちゃいのは100円も行かない気がし
ます30円この犬を30円とかじゃないか
なBバーストのぬいぐるみ
可愛いけど100円だと思いますハム太郎
の仲間50円ぐらいだと思う人キャラもの
100円東京リベンジャーズファンが多い
ので150円
骨持ってる犬100円マイメロちゃんの
ユニコーンの姿2002円マジで
ぬいぐるみの相場がわかんない売ったこと
あまりないからたべっこ動物の場に10円
カービィかわいいけど中古でしょな
100円100円ぐらいじゃない
メロンパンナちゃんアンパンマン系は
ちょっとね高い気がしますよ50円
ミツバチニャンなんか可愛いですねこれも
値段張りますよ多分30円チェーンソー
マンマキマさんいや
欲しかった動画のためなら売ります人気
アニメですからまあ200円ぐらいとか
じゃないかなスパイファミリーロイドさん
あーねほどではないかな100円売れるん
かなこういうのマジわかんないけど中間の
ちっちゃいマスコットみたいなやつ3匹
100円いかない気がするな3つで50円
だと思います
lohyマリオカートのルイージいやこれ
マジで10円
置いてあったからねそもそも値段つくんか
なものによっては値段つかない気もしてき
たぞちょっとお菓子とかもわかんないな
セブンティーンの看板
適当な値段つけたらファンに怒られそうだ
なええ1200円
缶バッジとしての価値ですからね50円
ですカービィのトミカこれは人気があり
そうだなまあ300円とかかなカービィの
マスコット100円そんないかんなごめん
なさい50円これ俺確か取るのに
7000円近く7800円かかってんだよ
ないや
可愛いけども
箱の外装がクレーンゲームで傷ついたりし
てるので300円とかじゃないんですが
言ってもちいかわのリュック
可愛いなぁ1個200円として400円
ぐらいいったら嬉しいですちいかは人気だ
から割といける気はしてるんだけどなこの
でっかいわんわんかわいいけど50円とか
じゃないかな
厳しい世界だと思いますこのボムボム
でかいな100円
何これリラックマの大きいクッション
ネームバリューもあるので200円
かわいいマジで普通に可愛いな多いねまあ
100円長野キャラクターラインサンダー
よく見るやつですねえー100円でっかい
シナモンロールちゃんこのサイズのは
なかなか見ないですね300円ぐらい
あたりかなと思います柴犬1
秋田県か秋田県100円はいかない気がし
ます50円ブルーなアニマルウサギ
めっちゃ綺麗なんだよなこれ個人的に価値
がある気がします200円すみっコぐらし
のクッションすみっコぐらしはもう人気な
のでこれはそこそこ
汚いなんかめっちゃゴミ付いてるから
えっと20円になりました全部のネコ
めっちゃ可愛いなぁ
でもまあ100円とかじゃないですか
100円マリオのキノコ人気ではあるが
朝鮮中古でしょうまあ100円クマさん
クッション30円アンパンマン200円
いや待ってお前いけるか
行ける
100円でかいボーナスで200円メタル
スライムのクッション
可愛い好きな人は好きそうね100円
LINEスタンプでよく見るやつ100円
です大きいので100円サメさん50円
マイメロンこのサイズ感かわいいですね
300円いけるよな
よし次はフィギュア行きますフィギュアは
俺のイメージだと高い気がするんですよ
景品として取れないのも高かったし売って
てもなんか高いのだと思います5000円
ぐらいいくよね物によってはいい値段する
気がしますトラファルがローのフィギュア
500円キャロットワンピースの
キャラクターなんだ俺は知らないから
300円ワンだ300円東京
リベンジャーズ
可愛いですねファンが多い見越して行って
も400円とかじゃないかな
やばい
バホってしちゃったゴールデンカムイ杉本
幸一マジでわからんまぁ主人公ということ
で500円
いやそんないかんやろ300円スパイ
ファミリー夜さんすごいです皆さんご覧
ください
背中がめちゃくちゃエロいエロボーナスも
加算されて700円ですマイクラ
エンダードラゴン子供たちの心に響くこと
によってこれはまあ600円ちっちゃい
トラファルガーローのフィギュア200円
今までメジロドーベルクオリティが高いの
で500円いったらいいかなまあ疲れたの
500円でお願いします5等分の花嫁
中野樹300円
わからんけどチェーンソーマンデンジ
200円かな男キャラより女キャラの方が
値が張るイメージはある
ランキング見る限り超トップのキャラでは
なかったんですよね200200とかじゃ
ないですかリコイルの明るい方いやアニメ
今終わってるんだよな200円なんか
軽いしょ20000円うるさいやつらの
ラムちゃん昔から人気なのでそこそこ行き
そうな気がするしクオリティーめっちゃ
高いんですよねこれは個人的には言って
欲しいな500円とかあったらいいほうか
と青春豚野郎はバニーガール先輩の夢を見
ない先輩2500円
僕の希望ですけどもおそらく300円とか
だと思いますラムちゃんの和風メイド
バージョンこれがもうラスボスだったしね
ラムちゃんもずっと高いイメージがあり
ました1000円とか言ったらマジでいい
と思いますそれなりに時間かけてとった
記憶がメタルスライムのマグカップ実用的
なので300円ぐらいすみっコぐらしのお
椀200円かなやばこれ破れてるこういう
のでちょっと価値が下がりますね
リラックマのマグカップこれ今の傷ついて
たらこれ3円ですマッサージ器具
100円とかな気がしますねクレーン
ゲームで撮ったらお菓子ですそもそも食品
が売れるかわかんないから売れない可能性
もあるんですけどもまぁ全部合わせて
1000円とかじゃないかなはいという
ことで全ての商品車に積み終わりました
ufoキャッチャーでガシャガシャしてる
から中古なんですよ箱とかも傷ついてるし
割と妥当な金額な気もしてます俺が操作
全ての合計金額
16,618円ですでもねマジでだいたい
こんなもんだと思うよ1万6000円より
上だったら素直に嬉しいですしこれより下
だったらそれなりに3日間ぐらい落ち込み
ます早速売りに行っていきたいと思います
売るお店静岡鑑定団さんの方に行きました
鑑定団グループっていうその何でも買って
くれるとこなんで多分買い取ってくれると
思います値段がつけばただ0円のものとか
もある可能性もあるしお菓子がそもそも
買い取ってくれるかどうかもわかんないの
でとりあえず1回持っていきたいと思い
ます
あとよろしくまだ
めっちゃ歩いてる
いや1500円とかだからレンジ
1500円あるかワンチャンありますね
これよろしくお願いします
はいというわけで
撮影してもらってます今ちょっとお話しし
たんですけどもやっぱ食品は売れない
みたいですね何やるかわかんないもんね
査定にかかる時間だいたい1時間ぐらいと
言われたのでちょっと1時間待ちたいと
思います
はいというわけで1時間ほど経過しました
無事に査定が終わったということで早速
行ってみたいと思います
[音楽]
はい大丈夫ですありがとうございます
ただいま帰りなさいますただいまです
査定が終わって帰ってきました結果から
言いましょう
俺すごいかもですすごいはい全部合わせた
金額なんと
こちら
17,000円でした
すごくないすごい
16,618円って言ってたんですよね
すごい
ほぼほぼ
誤差みたいなレベルで一番7000円でし
たほぼ合ってたしかもプラスだから勝って
たってことでしょ
売る時の金額感もあってたのかな内訳
ちょっと見ていきましょうか何が違ったん
だろうな何が高かったか気になるなウマ娘
マチカネタンホイザン500円水の
ドーベルが200円やっぱりキャラによっ
て値段がかなり変わりますねあーやっぱ
あとヒロアカは高いなフィギュア500円
600円とかえゴールデンカムイ800円
だった
結構高いなうるせえ奴らのラムちゃんが
600円相場のデンジャー200円まぁ
やっぱ変身後の方がかっこいいみたいな
とこなんだろうなエンダードラゴンが
300円5等分の花嫁の中のいつきちゃん
レム
枠名フィギュア
200円全然
価値がわかんないなぁ
可愛いだけとかではないのかもしれんな
一押ししてたあのスパイファミリーの夜
さんのフィギュア500円です
ワンピースのフィギュアマンダが500円
キャロットが400円東京リベンジャーズ
の千冬の可愛いやつ500円
トラファルガーローの穴大きいやつ
500円ピコリシリコイル200円
マッサージ機300円
着色ボールペン200円なんだけど
1本2円
のデフォルメされた可愛い人形が200円
ちいかわの窓付き収納ボックス800円
です
ちいかわのぬいぐるみリュック500円2
つで1000円ですいややっぱちいかわが
人気っぽいなこの感じはシナモロールの
でっかいぬいぐるみが500円青春豚野郎
はバニーガール先輩の夢を見ないマリー
さん200円ですドラゴンクエストのマグ
カップのスライム200円このでっかい
秋田犬のやつ500円しましたここ
意外とねなんか犬とかのぬいぐるみで高い
んだよねビーファーストのぬいぐるみも
300円のやつとか200円のやつとか
のマキバさん50円なの
ちょ回収してきていいですか
ビッグぬいぐるみってやつが800円です
リラックマのドーム型のクッションが
500円
ぬいぐるみはね結構ね
値段しますね思ったより会えないんだろう
あの俺たちがさ頑張ってあんにゃの
ちっちゃい箱のやつ7000円以上使った
じゃん俺確か7000近く使ったやつ
200円です
いややって7000円近くめっちゃお金
かけたやつが200円になるの心
居てなんか目立つ金額のはこれぐらいでし
た19万円近くかけてクレーンゲームで
撮った商品全部売ったところ輸送キング
16,618円だったのが
1万7000円でした
[音楽]